hello everyone in my previous video I
stated that Paul Morphy had a negative
score against Louie paulsen that'll
result in their eight games was five to
one impulse in favor but actually it's
the other way around more if you want
five classical games Paulsen won and
they drew two games and I would like to
thank hounds men read for a contribution
to my channel by pointing out this
mistake thank you a lot I really have no
idea why I said that I mean I even did a
video I think it was like last month or
something
how mr. Barnes actually had the best
result against mr. Murphy even if even
it was a terrible score but still the
best scorer than any player had against
Paul Morphy so yeah thank you for that
and let's get back to this game this is
round nine of the London chest classic
this is the last round and every player
has a lot hang in this game Carlson for
example has to win this game to win the
entire brand chest or he didn't have a
chance to win the London chest classic
but he can win the whole thing and
$150,000 prize fund and Aragon he he had
a fantastic 2017 he definitely wants to
win this game you know to improve the
standings this is the final tournament
he's playing in 2017 and he has the
white pieces Carson had a pretty bad
beat yesterday against nip oh and you
know having to play against Iranian with
the black pieces the next day is
definitely not something enjoyable
especially when this is like the fourth
day now that Carson is sick and you can
really see his sick he's like barely
doing the interviews so okay Ariane has
the white pieces any place d4 we have II
subs by Carlsen the horowitz defense
Knight to f3 c5 g3 C capture son d4
Knight capture son d4 and Queen to b6
Bishop to g2 now Bishop to c5 with a
double attack on the night III d5 now
and Queen to g4
attacking the g7 pawn and there are a
couple of ways Carl Carlson can deal
with this in the game Carson played
Bishop to f8 but I think probably King
to f8 is a better move
in g6 but he thought that Aragon
definitely had something prepared that
he didn't have anything in store for
Bishop to f8 so Bishop to f8 Aragon
castles Knight to f6 would attempt on
the Queen Queen to e5 now and here are a
nun played Queen to b5 check offering a
trade of Queens if you didn't do the
secret place something like Knight B 3
and then after Bishop g4 f3 Bishop d7 c4
going for that Center and after Queen to
a6 it will be a pretty fun game but then
then again it would be a whole different
game after E 5 Queen to b5 check Carlsen
block to Bishop d7 and now queen capped
for some b6 a capture some b6 and the
Queen's are off the board
night b3 getting the night out of the
way knight c6 Bishop to d2 now and
Bishop to d6 and Carlson said that when
he played this Bishop to d6 that he felt
terrible that he thought it was a really
really bad news Aragon here plays Knight
to c3 now attacking the d5 pawn twice
Knight to e7 defending the pawn and now
a 4 we have castles and now Knights to
b5 now attacking this s Carson said it's
terrible Bishop on d6 and you could play
something like Bishop b8 this is
definitely an option constricting this
night but then again you're cramping in
your own pieces so after Knight b5 the
cost and decided to give up the bishop
pair Bishop captures on b5 a capture
some b5 and rook a to c8 now attacking
the c2 pawn bishop to c3 we have h5 and
rook f2 d2 d1 now adding pressure to the
d5 pawn rook after the 8th 9th to d2 and
now H four okay Knight to f3 attacking
the pawn so pawn captures pawn captures
and E 4 now Knight to g5 Knight to g6
now and rook to a7 going after this
doubled beep on route to be a defending
Bishop to d4 now attacking the b6 pawn
Bishop to c5 by Carl
and RNN captures it captures captures
this does undable the points which kind
of seems like it's in Carlson's favor
but here comes c4 and now you can't
really pull the point if you pull the
point simply
RN wins upon and improves improves his
bone structure and you can't capture if
you captured and rook captures rook
captures and rope capture son b7 your
ee4 ponies attack this B beep on now
became a passed pawn and this is winning
for white
so after c4 Carlson played 93 7 we have
captures and Knight to c8 rook to a 4/9
to b6 now attacking the rook rook to a3
and here knife to c4 by Carlson
attacking the rook the problem with
capturing the pawn with knife captures
on d5 is rook to a7 and now after
something like rook to e8 knife captures
on e4 knife captors on e4 and rook
captures on d5 this pawn will be
captured very soon as the bishop is also
attacking it the night we'll have to
move either you just capture the night
and then pick up the c5 pawn this will
be this will be very nice for white for
example rookie 7 b6 and then wood ideas
of either capturing and then picking up
the c5 pawn or picking it up with the da
rook
so after rook to a3 Knights the c-4
attacking the rook rook to c3 Knight to
d6 now and now rook captures on c5 it's
a clean pawn rook to e8 Bishop to h3 now
rook to e8 rook to c7 and we have King
to f8 now b6 rook to e5 and here comes
the move that iron and probably
overestimated I mean he did say he
overestimated it in the in an interview
later with Maurice
he played knife to e6 check and everyone
was pretty surprised here I mean it's a
better position but Ireland said that he
knew that it was a better position but
that he felt that he had to deliver that
finishing blow
so he played 926 check and this doesn't
really work out as he planned one option
that definitely could have been played
and it's it but it's pretty much a drawn
line is night captures on f7 and after
night captures rook captures on b7 at
night to d8 attacking the rook rook c7
and now rook captures on d5 Rukia Trish
Knight captures attacking the rook but
now b7 Knight captures rook pawn
captures rook getting a queen Knight
captures on a 8 and now Bishop to g2
attacking the e4 pawn Knight b6 and
Bishop captures on e4 so black is better
here but who can actually win this as
black you only have one pawn if that
pawn falls I mean you can't deliver
checkmate with two knights although
maybe you could white still has some
pawns you know maybe it could mean maybe
it could be some fantastic study or
something but not likely
so after route to d5 RM played nice to
e6 with Czech Carson captured it he was
very glad to see this position he didn't
know if this was winning for white or
something but he definitely thought that
he had had something to hold on to F
captures on e6 D captures on e6 and now
Knight F to e a and this is the move
this is the move Aragon probably missed
he thought that after he recaptured that
he will have threats against the d6
night but now comes and you can't even
if you captured the night simply Knight
captures this rook not this rope this
bone will never become a passer so after
rook to d7 rope to a5 b for now
rook a to d5 rook to a-1 rook to be 5
again rook to e8 but now rook captures
on b6 and this is this is a very
important point that are again just lost
Bishop to g4 rook to d5 King to g2
capture some before grabbing Carlsen
grabs another pawn rook to a1 rugby to
b5 Bishop to e2 now and there is a
verily
Aaron can do here it's simply a much
better position for Carlson now rope to
be to attacking the bishop Bishop g4 now
rook d2 d2 going for the f2 pawn king to
h3 now rook captures King to h4 and now
rope to h2 check and this is this is
over if you if you try something like
for example Bishop to h3 okay best
registry was played but now comes g5 and
now you have to play something like King
to h5 and give up the bishop if you
don't if you play something like Knight
to g4 then comes Knight to f6 check
again you have to capture here and then
you lose the rook pawn captures King is
now blocking the queening square root to
a8 threatening to promote but now Knight
to f7 checking the King and also
covering the queening square so after
King H for rugby t2 now the point is
gonna fall and it's it's game over
so after g5 are even played King h5
crossing out grabs a piece team to g6
now rope to f2 e 7 check King to g8 and
here are in and tries one more idea rook
captures and e6 and you can't capture
rook but this this was ok it was another
opportunity for Carlsen maybe to blunder
if Knight Patras then rook to e8 check
Knight to c8 rook after c8 Rock f8 and
he captures f8 with Queen and this
checkmate I'm gonna have to work after
Sun b6 simply rope to h7 by Carlson and
in this position 11 aragon resigned the
game and cousin won the grand chester at
there's no point in continue in this
position after something like rook to b6
simply rook checks king h5 now King to
f7 threatening Knight f6 check but you
can't really do anything about this row
k5 Knight of 6 check if you go King h6
then rook to h2 is checkmate if you
don't you have to capture the night rook
captures rook captures and now we were
simply down the rook and and the pawn
you know no point no point in continuing
this so okay after rook to h7 Armenian
resigned the game and once again a very
nice game by Carlson although as Yaser
said it this is a more of a more of an
Iranian loss than it is a Carlson win
but after that bad beat against Napa
yesterday definitely a nice turnaround
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I will probably cover some
more games from dawn jazz classics still
waiting for a Kiwanis game against
Michael Adams to finish to see who
actually won the London chest classic so
until that happens I would like to thank
Timothy Michael I'd say for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and a special
video for the end of this video
I received a thank you video from Luca
which the winner of the champion chess
set the the main prize of my fifty
thousand subscribers giveaway so here it
is I will let you guys see it it's a
very short less than a minute so here it
is
so there it is that was looking over to
the winner of the championship chess set
thank you looking for this amazing video
thank you thank you a lot I hope you
really enjoyed the chess set and for
those of you who want a challenge Lu
Conley chess I will put his username in
the description below because you really
can't see it on that piece of paper so
yeah thank you for watching as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I already said thank you for watching
but I will see you soon